you said
jorge ochoa was perhaps the brains
of the medellin cartel
what was he like and why do you say he
was the brains
well he was a gentleman and i suppose
he's
shipped and don't tell me how many more
times of cocaine than pablo did
just in him and his brothers you could
tell by the they had on each
hl load they was in duffel bags and
there's big
football shaped fluffy stuff
made with ether and they would have
three horns on it or a rattlesnake or
four x's on each bag
you kind of got to knowing which was
which was which and they shipped a lot
so um and he was just a gentleman i took
the family we went one weekend to his
ranch or his uh malaysia place
out near barangay and oh
we he just treated the family and his
family had a
his younger brother made a bull fight
and
we had skiing and
little airplanes on floats on the water
it was really nice and he was really
nice
how do you make sense of the tension
that a man could be a gentleman can have
integrity but also be a murderer
well murder is is a is a stronger word
than killing
can you explain the the the line the
gray area we're talking about
i mean i've just talking with jocko
willing and we talked a lot about
killing in the context of uh
military conflict and context of war
so there there's a line between murder
and killing that you can draw
what's the line that you're referring to
it's something similar
if you if people shooting at you and you
shoot back and kill him i don't that's
not murder whatsoever
it's uh he's trying to get away or out
of the situation
but if uh some woman don't pay you and
you send a hit man over
to to kill her and her children that's
that's that's my last murder
was jorge involved in those kinds of
things i don't think so it only just
i mean he was he was just such a
gentleman he had a a restaurant before
and
and he was just smart i understand that
uh the first
10 kilos he sold he was sitting on them
on a motorcycle in the
in the sidelines in a parking lot when
the dea come in he sped away
so he didn't come back to america he was
just smart some people just have
are savvy and he was such a gentleman
and the whole family the mother and the
father
the two brothers their sister it was i
was there when she was kidnapped
and uh finally he kidnapped our
i guess 100 liters of the farc
and uh said all right she don't come
back none of these are going to come
back
so they made a deal
you